what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off Parker Lewis is the
head of business development at
Unchained Capital in this conversation
we discussed Bitcoin the value
proposition why people should care and
then we go through each of the latest
writings of Parker including the ones
titled gradually then suddenly Bitcoin
can't be copied bitcoin is not too
volatile bitcoin does not waste energy
bitcoin is not too slow bitcoin fixes
this and Bitcoin not blockchain I really
enjoyed this conversation and I hope you
do as well skirt school want to know who
has the best URL crypto comm that's
right crypto comm there are crypto
platform with one goal mother in mass
adoption that's why we're all here we're
trying to get crypto in every wallet
crypto comm is helping people do that
through buying earning lending and card
payment everything you could want at
crypto comm go help your boy out tell
them pump sent you download the app or
visit crypto comm pumps got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry
your boy pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla is over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mind comm tell them tom sent
you and thank me later as many of you
know crypto investors store their
digital assets on exchanges or in cold
storage for long-term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall
with the new block by interest account
users can now securely store their
Bitcoin or ether at block 5 and receive
6% annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency 6% is an absurdly high
rate it's the best rate in the industry
I highly suggest you go check out block
by.com slash pop again that's block 5
calm slash pop to sign up and start
earning crypto today if you follow
Bitcoin and crypto you've probably heard
of eToro they're the world's number one
social trading platform and I love it
they've got more than 10 million other
traders that love it too and guess what
they just launched the United States
eToro offers access to the world's most
popular crypto currencies including
Bitcoin etherium and others with the
smartest trading tools and the ability
to connect with the best traders around
the world there's no better place to
build your perfect portfolio if you're
new to Bitcoin and crypto you can test
the waters with their $100,000 virtual
trading feature but if you're more
experienced you can create custom
technical charts and use eToro social
feeds to inform your trading decisions
they've got transparent fees and so you
never miss out they also have an
easy-to-use application available on
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks
at each row calm again that's eToro comm
get VIP access it's a bit coin and
crypto markets today Anthony pomp Leon o
is a partner at Morgan Creek digital all
opinions expressed by pomp or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
capital management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I am here with
Parker we were actually just having a
conversation and I said stop we need to
just go record this so you guys could
all hear this out thanks so much for
doing this yeah absolutely glad to be
here in Wyoming the whole blockchain
taskforce y/o hackathon
I'm happy to be up here and learning how
we can help Wyoming in advance the
Bitcoin community up here for sure let's
start with just your background you know
you've kind of had this is pretty
interesting journey to Bitcoin and then
what when she saw it kind of some of
things you've done so just start with
what you were doing before Bitcoin yeah
so I was working for a hedge fund global
macro hedge fund at the time in Dallas
human capital it's a fun run by Kyle
bass you know yeah when I first started
working there was distressed credit
long/short equity but over time a lot of
the focus of the fund was global macro
and so that was at the time that I was
also starting to learn about Bitcoin
2014/2015 didn't really start to click
for me until 2016 once it did went full
down the rabbit hole partly as a
function of doing research for the hedge
fund that I was at but also just you
know trying to re-educate myself on what
money was and so the more that I started
to understand not only why Bitcoin
exists but also how it worked
Mike it became more and more convinced
that what I wanted to be doing with my
time was not working for a hedge fund
but going to figure out how I could
contribute to the Bitcoin ecosystem and
create and create value for sure and so
today what are you doing because because
you were there you did a bunch of work
with Kyle went really deep on Bitcoin
how it fits into that global macro
environment what it meant for
institutional investors to try to get
access to it etc but now you've gone
kind of full-fledged and jumped in in
the crypto world so you talk a little
bit unchained what you're doing there
yeah so I lead our business development
efforts at Unchained so helping to guide
this strategy you know kind of form a
vision around what it is that we want to
be and really what that is is kind of
recognizing a world where we're at this
very early point and the shift in really
the global monetary order and if say a
1% of people own Bitcoin and 99 percent
don't how can we contribute to that and
in really where we focus our efforts is
helping to people better secure their
Bitcoin so we offer a Bitcoin multi
signature vault what
which allows people to control their own
keys and we in that process and help add
incremental security to someone who is
currently facilitating self custody
generally with a single key we offer
also offer lending one of our you know
monikers or principles that we that we
live by as friends don't let friends
sell Bitcoin we also we also lend
against Bitcoin which which does have
risks and trade-offs but but you know
one of the primary reasons why people
borrow against their Bitcoin is because
they don't want to sell it so it
represents a tax tax efficient way to
access some dollar liquidity while
preserving an appreciating asset in a
very scarce asset for sure I love the
friends don't let friends help Bitcoin
internally we joke all the time and it's
a joke but we say sellings for
non-believers right say yeah same sort
of theme there yeah and it's really one
of the other things I've started to work
on as part of my function with Unchained
is a new series that I've been writing
on on Bitcoin and and kind of helping
helping others in in hopefully a more
accessible way to understand partly my
path but then also in just a broader
educational effort to help people
understand what is a very complex medium
of why you don't want to sell Bitcoin
why you why you should be accumulating
it because I think for anybody who's
around the periphery they can they can
see from the outside looking in a very
volatile asset you know why would I ever
do this it seems you know very esoteric
very complicated which it is but the
more that you understand about how it
actually works and why it exists the
more conviction that you have and as a
consequence that the greater your
ability is to to manage you know your
your own exposure to it your own
portfolio and in to remain in it and
tolerate the the significant swings for
sure so I definitely wanna get into the
writing because frankly it's fantastic
maybe one of the better series that that
I've ever read but before we get into
that let's just talk about Bitcoin in
the global macro environment right so
you know you had the pleasure of working
closely with with Kyle bass on this
we've had on the podcast and I think has
a lot of you know I would say powerful
thoughts around global macro and the
they like Bitcoin how that fits in maybe
give us your view on where does this fit
in and then how do you see that evolving
given some of the macro-environment
developments that are occurring today
whether it's the u.s. repo market issues
that we're seeing China Hong Kong and
all that kind of stuff yeah absolutely
and that you know one of the ways that I
also came to Bitcoin was I was
independently doing research for haman
on Bitcoin specifically but separate and
apart from that I was also doing work on
the financial crisis you know obviously
Kyle has history having shorted the
subprime crisis I wasn't at Heyman at
the time and just so people understand
Kyle is probably one of maybe six people
who now is shorted the housing crisis
but made a very large bet from an
aggregate dollar amount obviously it was
correct and kind of built a reputation
around having this contrarian thought
that ended up proving out and so that's
what uh
as what Parker is referring to yeah and
so at the time this was 2016 2017 the
Fed had begun to they basically tapered
their incremental purchases they had
begun raising short-term interest rates
but they had but they hadn't touched the
balance sheet and so the work that I was
doing independent from the research I
was doing on Bitcoin was really
understanding the the transmission
mechanism of quantitative easing and
trying to understand what then would
happen when the Fed unwound its balance
sheet which it which it ultimately began
in November of 2017 and so as I was
going down those parallel paths they
ultimately converged with the principal
conclusion that essentially where QE
starts and ends is really the the Y of
Bitcoin in terms of what it is here to
disrupt and what problem it ultimately
solves and so the the way that I the way
that I look at the macro world is and
this is something that you know as part
of my own education and in kind of
reading resources like the Bitcoin
standards but but really re-educating
myself or really educating myself for
the first time on what the question of
what
money is and and I think that's really
the context that people need to think
about Bitcoin is you know it is
competing with the like its legacy
monetary system and in principally the
dollar as a reserve currency the euro
the yen really fiat systems anywhere and
when I think about kind of the Fed and
the global context it is that the the
global credit systems and the way that
they're constructed require not as a
possibility but as a necessity for those
systems continue to exist QE is an
inevitability without additional QE
those credit systems would collapse on
themselves and so I think we can talk a
little bit about what's happening in the
repo market but you know if if we expand
out from you know kind of the initial
kind of 75 billion of injections it is
you know there's a lot more to come and
it's not on there were magnitude of tens
of billions it's it's trillions of
dollars and it's not just the Fed it's
the ECB and it's the it's the Bank of
the Japan and it's in this really any
central bank that has the ability to do
it and the the root cause of that is
that the financial system as its
constructed is massively levered so if
we just think about the dollar system
alone there's about 73 trillion of
dollar denominated debt excluding
derivatives just fixed liability fixed
maturity as tracked by the Fed today in
the banking system there's only about
one point six trillion actual reserves
so every dollar is essentially leveraged
40 times over that is the consequence of
30 to 40 years of every time the credit
system has tried to readjust or just has
tried as a system to deliver essentially
been in a been sustained as a function
of smaller cubies along the way that
ultimately will lead to kind of
instability in the credit system which
we're starting to see where yeah you
know if banks want to access overnight
credit in in the repo markets paying 10%
interest like that is a
the strings the only way to solve
liquidity strings is to put more base
money in and so that's what we're seeing
with repo I think what we'll see very
soon from there is you know more
large-scale asset purchases so QE 4 QE
and infinity and then when you think
about that in the context of Bitcoin if
if the Fed system or the or the ECB
system or the Bank of Japan system is
dependent on a expanding credit system
as a consequence dependent on an
increase in the base money supply
Bitcoin as a fixed supply reserve asset
but outcompetes that and so for people
who have the ability to opt out of the
legacy system and as they educate
themselves on Bitcoin they will see the
contrast where each time you know every
10 years or I think increasingly so we
either go into a form of a credit crisis
or an expansion of the base money supply
people will increasingly start to ask
questions and say hey maybe this is why
Bitcoin XS maybe this is a better
alternative and ultimately what we're
gonna see on the free market is that
it's a competition between two monetary
systems the legacy system that's
dependent on future drowns of QB or a
free market system that tolerates
volatility but at the root of it is is
backed by effect supply for sure and
into you know look that there's a ton
here and I think part of what makes it
so exciting to you know folks like you
and I is that it's a very complex
analysis right you have to understand
what is money you've got to understand
some of the macro stuff you've got to
understand QE and central bank kind of
incentives and tools at their disposal
you've got to understand Bitcoin is
technology its monetary supply right
there's just a bunch packed into what is
a pretty simple analysis do I get
exposure to Bitcoin or not right you
keep bringing up this idea of like what
is money maybe talk a little bit about
just like how you describe that to
people today yeah and again this is
something that I think most people have
never asked that question and I
certainly I myself up until four or five
years ago had
that question saying and I think that
there especially those that that look at
the dollar system there's confusion as
to or there's explanations that it's
just a collective hallucination or our
money is just a belief system but I
think at a root level it's a it is a
man-made invention but it is a tool that
enables specialization division of labor
and and I think in that context and as
I've educated myself nick szabo shelling
out sayfudine a Moose's bitcoin standard
thinking about kind of really at a first
principle level why it is you know let's
just you know restrict it to a
conversation about the united states why
are 325 million people all walking
around you know willing to accept this
form of paper or the digital
representation of that paper in exchange
for real-world goods and services and
and and I think that that discussion as
to how the dollar emerge and why the
dollar exists is is it is a complicated
discussion but ultimately I think what
people have to recognize is that there
is rhyme and reason to money there are
inherent properties that make something
a better or worse form of money and that
also our current economy and then how
complex it is with the degrees of
specialization and the degrees of
division of labor our economies don't
work without money and money is
ultimately the the good that facilitates
the coordination of all other economic
activity and when we think about the
properties of something that makes
something a better form of money versus
a worse form of money have if we were
reducing it to a few few topics as
relative scarcity it's the the ability
to transact them so the divisibility of
that unit fungibility there's a lot of
discussion in Bitcoin whether Bitcoin is
sufficiently fungible and I think
there's ways that you know Bitcoin will
become increasingly fungible but where
we sit today I view Bitcoin as equally
as fungible as the dollar and so when we
think about relative scarcity the
visibility portability when you start to
think about Bitcoin relative to other
in the market that is why it's emerging
and for the principal reason that it is
finitely scarce and prior to Bitcoin no
form of money was finitely scarce now
the explanation as to how and why
bitcoin is scarce is really really the
tangible question that when I talk to
people that's what I do I tell them to
try to understand because it because it
isn't just some coincidence that that
it's finitely scarce there's an
interplay between the technical
architecture of Bitcoin the way that
bitcoins consensus mechanism works but
also the economic incentives of the
underlying currency that tie everything
together yeah and I think that the whole
idea of this like finite scarcity is I
used like real estate all time right I
say look if you look at the city of
Manhattan for example it's an island
they're not gonna make more land and so
what ends up happening is as more and
more people want to move there or have
ownership of that land the price
increases right and all of that is just
simply supply and demand economics which
is a very simple idea it's something
that's taught in you know economics 101
and things like that but because it is
so simple a lot of folks who either
don't buy into the Bitcoin story and
thesis or those who ignore it I think
it's just that they overlook the simple
thing right and it's almost like it's so
simple that they're like no there has to
be something more there has to be a more
intellectually driven conversation and
some of it you're hinting at you know
kind of once you get past that supply
and demand but ultimately that's where
the the quote-unquote US dollar value
comes from right is just as demand
increases if you have a fixed supply
asset the price has to go up unless all
of a sudden supply demand economics are
in doubt right and I think that you know
I think people fall out on two sides of
this where it you know the first
question is I don't believe that it's
actually scarce yep
and there's a lot of confusion around
how and why that is or or why it's not
the case that well if I just create
another cryptocurrency that that that
represents you know in aggregate digital
currency inflation so there's there's
diffusing around both of those points as
to to whether or not you know Bitcoin
independently can maintain a scare
supplier or how to think about that
scarcity relative to other digital
assets and then beyond that you know and
this is something that I struggled with
myself it was this concept of well if
Bitcoin has a fixed supply and as and
its value continues to rise
you know if bitcoins 10,000 a coin or a
hundred thousand coins it's too
expensive for people to get and really
that that is that is a mental block that
people have to work through where it's
you know the way that I you know and one
of my friends helped me think through
this it's actually the more valuable you
know what you know one Bitcoin is an
arbitrary unit you know the way that I
think about it is the economic
about is an economic system and the
purchasing power of the network as a
whole and so if that's approximately 200
billion today the more valuable that
Bitcoin is the more valuable it becomes
the the the less of a unit of Bitcoin
that you need to to transmit value of
our communication channel that about
that network is actually more valuable
and so you know the people struggle with
the fact that well you know how is the
rest of the world going to be able to to
access enough you know a certain
percentage of the network to make it
significant enough and that really isn't
the point it's you just need a piece of
the network and and as more people at da
Bitcoin and as its met with a fixed
supply the the the the overall value of
the network increases it's not just that
Bitcoin you know denominated in dollars
increases is that the the the
communication channel as a whole
increases in value because there are now
more nodes connected to it if there are
only 60 million people transacting in
Bitcoin
that's very limited but if a billion
people own Bitcoin and are transacting
it every day the value of that network
increases and the only way to get there
is by incremental adoption which
ultimately increases the value of
Bitcoin it's a cellphone example right
it just one cell phone in the world
isn't very valuable even just two cell
phones in the world isn't very valuable
because you can only call one other
person right it's when you have an
entire network of thousands tens of
thousands hundreds and then ultimately
millions of devices now that network
becomes much much more valuable because
each person who joins is actually
driving value in that network
- you know some point and so I think
that you know that example is not
exclusive to money or to Bitcoin it
exists in other markets we just don't
think of them that way right yeah and in
really when you kind of get into various
different layers of Bitcoin and start to
understand the network effects it is
that you know the more people that come
into Bitcoin they just want to purchase
that as an asset and use it you know
whether for speculative purposes or
increasingly over time as they learn
more as a true store of wealth and as a
way to to convert the value that they
create into - you know what we all
believe in the future will be a stable
form of money that increasingly those
people then begin to actually contribute
value by building infrastructure you
know you know I think it's a it's
probably an overused and I overuse it
but rome wasn't built in a day you know
you don't have to be building
infrastructure for a Bitcoin or
contributing as a as you know either an
investor or as somebody that that is
curating content or creating content if
if you create value in the real world
and then choose to store that that coin
you are increasing the value of the
network as a whole for sure holders are
users right yeah yeah and then that's
you know the what money is is a store of
value and that if we think about it at a
root level of converting time to value
to Bitcoin or a form of money and and
safe talks about this in his book we're
kind of thinking about kind of the time
preference or what I consume today
versus what I consume in the future
anything that we're choosing to save is
putting off what we could consume today
for some for some future investment and
I think that there are serious not
necessarily consequences are there are
massive ramifications as more people
start to think about time preference
high time preference low time preference
how they choose to spend today versus
save and then kind of how they how they
how they think about the the trade-offs
and I think this is a concept that safe
talks about and it's really interesting
where where he talks about you know
would be a macro economics in macro
economics think about
kind of the the trade-offs in
transactions between different
participants in an economy whereas time
preference is more of a trade-off
between you yourself in your future self
and so kind of thinking about Bitcoin in
that context the more people that are
choosing to store wealth in Bitcoin in a
stable form of money there are there I
think there will be ramifications far
greater than just you know Bitcoin and
the dollar and the Bitcoin monetary
system and legacy monetary system but if
you have a world of a billion people
that now are operating an environment
where there's a reintroduction of
opportunity costs of money there will be
a an increasing focus on productive
activities and so I think you know it's
far ranging in terms of the impact for
sure so I want to jump into this series
that you've been writing first of all
where can people go find this series and
then we'll kind of go point by point of
each each of the was that you've
published recently yeah so I published
generally every Fridays I had you know
there have been a few things that have
come up that have prevented the last
couple weeks but I released it after the
post every Friday and I posted on
Twitter but then you can find it on our
on our blog at unchain - capital slash
blog got it all right so the first one
it was kind of like a shot over the bow
cuz I didn't even know this was
happening and then all of a sudden you
write this thing gradually then suddenly
described you know kind of at a high
level what exactly you were trying to
communicate in that first piece yeah so
when one to give some credit kind of
over the course of the last year or two
years I had seen Marty bent writing a
Daily News shout-out Marty yeah and I
know you write a daily or daily or
weekly newsletter say for a book you
know one of the things I think you know
yourself and Peter McCormick yesterday
echo that education is such a critical
piece and so and I've you know benefited
immensely from the the content that
others have created we as an
organization kind of view while we're
trying to serve a certain kind of
segment of the market that value self
custody
we also want to help expand the the
knowledge base and and bring more people
in the Bitcoin and I think from from my
past having worked at a global macro
hedge fund now kind of working everyday
within within the Bitcoin spheres
helping to create a bridge or an
accessible medium that isn't necessarily
you know as long as a book but that can
give eat whether it's family offices
other institutional investors a a look
through into my own thought process as
to how I've arrived from not ever
questioning what money is to being being
a everyday full-time working on on
building infrastructure for Bitcoin and
so that that was the primary goal it was
to really distill for myself but then
you know to create a depository or a
repository of not necessarily academic
but just educational resources to
hopefully if people are interested in
the question of why are so many people
interested in Bitcoin that that they can
come and and think about things that
that generally represent mental blocks
that's one of the things that I I try to
focus on is is distilling complex
subjects that hang up a lot of people
and explain at least you know in in you
know the context of my background and in
the way that I think about it how you
know they may think about a certain
problem that may prevent them from kind
of advancing their on their path of
seeing bitcoins money for sure and so
the the idea of gradually then suddenly
as you look at this is this kind of the
starting point of where you think people
can you know kind of enter into this the
mindset of this isn't just speculative
asset there's an actual kind of more
macro you know kind of systemic
perspective to look at this specific
currency and that's why you started
there yeah
yeah really kind of providing that that
that big overarching thousand foot view
the question of why I mean that and
that's really where I started the piece
and in the reason why I turned that
gradually than suddenly it's it was a
term penned by by Hemingway and a thing
that the Sun Also Rises but it was also
the idea of you know one how how people
go bankrupt gradually then suddenly that
that's very much how I think about the
concept our context of of defense
economic system where it is a massively
levered put you know probably massively
insolvent system and it's and it's
happened very gradually but then when it
unwise it happens suddenly I think that
the first crack in that facade was was
the financial crisis but then it's also
kind of also applies to the context of
how I came to Bitcoin when I was
thinking about it I thought of myself as
you know you know staring at a wall that
had a mural on it but only seeing a
blank canvas and then there were there
were a few kind of conversations or
talking with my friends who had been
involved in Bitcoin for a long time or
then suddenly something clicked for me
I mean I add like in certain cases I
specifically remember like the the place
in time where I was you know what the
specific specific mental block was and
then what it was it helped me kind of
overcome that and so you know a primary
reason for writing this is thinking back
to the that up that kind of process that
I went through and then trying to
distill those thoughts down so people
can start there and then they can move
on to more longer form subjects like the
Bitcoin standard or mastering Bitcoin
which I believe is a great resource as
well as inventing Bitcoin by Yong
Pritzker so really it is for people who
are you know have that question of what
is this thing it presents you know eight
digestible accessible medium generally
three thousand four thousand words where
someone can sit down and then kind of
start to peel back the layers of the
onion for sure and so the second piece
you wrote was a Bitcoin can't be copied
which you know is a a pretty common yet
relatively lazy
I think detraction of just oh there's
Bitcoin then there's two thousand three
thousand other tokens right so like it's
just the same thing over and over again
what differentiates Bitcoin but maybe
talk a little bit about
some of the thoughts in that piece of
Bitcoin can't be copied yeah and I think
it is a very maybe shallow isn't the
right term but it's not a deep thought
process that but it is one that's
prevalent a lot among a lot of people on
the periphery of this idea that well you
know yeah there's 21 million bitcoins
but the 21 million bitcoins cash or you
know I don't know how many aetherium
there will ever be but this idea that
copying Bitcoin or creating a new
digital currency does not replicate the
monetary properties that are inherent in
Bitcoin and I think that I think this is
the way that I communicated it the piece
it's you know as kids were all taught
that money doesn't grow on trees and
then suddenly Bitcoin you know has its
Immaculate Conception and you know the
way I think about caches lightning in a
bottle
when Bitcoin was released it wasn't
money you know in the in the days
subsequent it wasn't money in the
probably years subsequent it wasn't
money but that overtime monetary
properties emerged in the network and
it's a little bit confounding to me that
you know where we are where we are at
today in Bitcoin where it's this
emerging monetary technology protocol
that you know currently has a purchasing
power of about 200 billion dollars and
if we look back in history in kind of
skip past the the immersion of fiat
systems which leveraged gold but they're
really thinking in the context that
money's haven't emerged on a free market
since gold and silver and and those
emerged over the course of thousands of
years here we are sitting with this new
form of monetary technology and everyone
suddenly you know despite being taught
and despite being a hyper intuitive that
Bitcoin or that money doesn't grow on
trees oh let's all just go create our
own form of money and so the the point
of that piece bitcoin can't be copy was
was really trying to emphasize the
things that make Bitcoin unique and in
some base layer to think about why
monetary systems converge to one
why you know an economy converges around
a single medium of exchange and
ultimately uses that medium of exchange
as a unit of account that well well it
should seem intuitive that everybody you
know around the world shouldn't be able
to create their money they in fact can't
and it's really based in the monetary
properties that have emerged around
Bitcoin the censorship resistance the
decentralization and ultimately those
two kind of properties that that are not
inherent in other cryptocurrencies that
really reinforce the scarcity that is
bitcoins 21,000,000 supply because
without those properties of
decentralization without censorship
resistant 21 million is not a credible
number but so long as it is and so long
as the value of Bitcoin increases the
network becomes increasingly
decentralized increasingly censorship
resistance which further reinforces the
the credibility of a fixed supply which
will continue to cause really cause
value to converge around the Bitcoin
network because it's a better before
money yeah and it's interesting because
a lot of times I talk about or my answer
to the question of like what is Bitcoin
is Bitcoin is something different to
different people right and so these
elements of non C's ability non
censorship the hard cap you know just a
whole bunch of different aspects or
criteria that have formed for this value
that you're describing certain people
find different aspects of that more
valuable than the other aspects of
Bitcoin right so if you're sitting in
somewhere and you're worried about
people seizing your wealth all of a
sudden the C's ability or the lack
thereof it becomes super super important
right if you're sitting there and you're
worried about censorship
well now the fact that it can't be
censored becomes really really important
and it's not so much just that one group
over another group finds certain
elements more valuable than others but
also you as an individual may find
different elements more or less valuable
at different times as well right you
could see a world where at one point in
time you actually really care about the
fact that it's not seasonal but then at
another point in your life you know in a
relatively short period or over a long
period of time now the censorship
becomes important or the monetary policy
becomes important and so the the fact
that there is such a DC
lies governance to this and the lack of
kind of rapid change really allows
people to find what's most viable to
them in my opinion yeah and I also think
about that and I believe I wrote about
this in the in the initial piece that I
did is that everybody has to come to
this relying on their own life
experience and if they if they just
looked at this simplistically based on
what they had been taught in high school
or college or you have you know just
looked at it at a incumbent economic
view they would never come to the view
that bitcoin is money in a vacuum but
that over time as people look at this
they relate to it and you know through
their own eyes and through their own
lens and bitcoin emerges as money to
each individual for different reasons
reasons on different timelines and then
the aggregate consequence of that is
that these properties emerge in terms of
the overall network but that you know
Bitcoin there wasn't a sudden point in
time where Bitcoin became money it
becomes money to each individual as they
educate themselves and as they you know
kind of form a mental model as to how to
think about it or what properties of
that network are attracted to them but
then it's also in the context that it's
always relative to something else and so
when I am choosing to store my value in
Bitcoin I'm choosing not to store it in
another monitoring network but but you
can't do that in increasing ways without
having formed your own perspective as to
how this helps you not only today but
into the future and that's that that
will always inherently be dependent on
have each individual's own circumstances
their own life experiences and their
kind of the way that they look at the
world skirt school want to know who has
the best URL crypto calm that's right
crypto calm there are crypto platform
with one goal mother mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet crypto
calm is helping people do that through
buying earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto calm
go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mind it's like an
Xbox or a PlayStation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you'll plug it in connect to your
Wi-Fi five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine com tell
them pom Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor block
five their new interest account allows
you to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive six
percent annual interest paid monthly in
cryptocurrency this rate actually
compounds so you receive a 6.2 percent
APY which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block Phi and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block v
comm / pop again block 5 comm / pump to
sign up and start earning interest on
your crypto today the next piece in the
series is Bitcoin is not too volatile
elaborate on that a little bit yeah so
this is one that I think probably at
deeper levels and more reasonably causes
people to struggle around ok so there's
a group of whack jobs out there saying
the Bitcoin is money but every time I
look on the screen it changes you know
five percent or it's down 20 percent
over you know a month or you know or a
twenty percent twenty percent like how
could that ever be money that that
concept is foreign to what I know money
to be but realistically and the BJ boy
potty had a great quote on this Stefan
laverre podcast where he said that I'm
gonna butcher the the quote but it was
along the lines of
establishment yeah establishment
economists to ride the fact that bitcoin
is volatile as something as if something
can go from not existing to a stable
form of money overnight and what were
what we're realistically seeing right
now is the monetization of a good on the
free market for the first time since
gold there's no way for that to happen
without volatility right now if you know
again I have no idea how many you know
literally how many people use Bitcoin
but thinking about it in the order of
magnitude of sixty million or seventy
million people everyone is trying to
figure out exactly what this is what the
future of it will be how resilient it
will be what we're witnessing in terms
of volatility is price discovery as
orders of magnitude more people are
educating themselves and beginning to
adopt Bitcoin and beginning to you know
at a base level starting out with a very
small percentage of their wealth but
then as they learn more increasing and
while that adoption is increasing by
orders of magnitude its met with a fixed
supply so if we think about adoption
waves and again we don't know specific
numbers but thinking of each adoption
way of representing an order of
magnitude so from 2016 today may be
something like five million to 260
million or ten million to 100 million
whatever it may be is that relative
increase in demand met with a supply
that over that same period only
increased by 10 percent that that fixed
supply is what creates the volatility
but it is also the fundamental source of
demand people are looking this they're
starting to ask themselves for the first
time in their lives what is money and
whether bitcoin is a superior successor
to the legacy systems
there's no way to educate yourself on
bitcoin and it has a market too you know
all of a sudden at one time converge on
a stable form of value and so the
bitcoins volatility is a natural
function of that those adoption dynamics
and in the ultimate supply curve of
Bitcoin and that over time if we think
about the store value people in Bitcoin
who who have been around for a year or
two years or three years they think
about in in the context of longer time
horizons
day to day and then in addition to that
it's important to recognize that Bitcoin
doesn't exist in a vacuum and so if
you're an institutional investor and
thinking about you know how can I have
exposure to Bitcoin with all this
volatility the way that I think about it
is in the context of the diversification
of an entire portfolio so bitcoins
volatility is muted when you think about
you know a 1% position or a 5% position
and what are the attributes of or what
is one of the valid volatility of other
assets that you hold but that when you
look at the dynamics and why Bitcoin has
a fundamental demand that being that it
has a fixed supply that over any long
time horizon that you look at Bitcoin
whether it's 3 months 6 months 1 year 2
years it is storing value whereas the
dollar may be stable day to day but if
you look at the long term chart of the
purchasing power of the dollar if it
loses value by design and so central
bankers all over the world have you know
kind of know chastised Bitcoin as being
you know no one uses it as a as a method
of payment it's too volatile to being
currency when in reality we're just
witnessing price discovery on the
logical path of a monetization of a good
on the free market which is you know a
fundamentally disruptive idea absolutely
and I think that's part of the power of
it right which is once people understand
that then you know as you said I really
like this idea of cuz it was my journey
I think it's most people's journey it's
also you test it out a little bit right
and you start to store a little bit of
wealth and then you gain confidence you
gain understanding you gain conviction
really and then it very slowly you start
to put more and more of your wealth into
this asset and eventually you know
people start getting to very high
percentages of their wealth stored once
they're educated and they're convicted
which i think is a you know a lot of
people will just follow that path yeah
and I also think by definition when you
buy Bitcoin for the first time or make
that leap often likely for speculative
reasons you by definition know very
little and and that that first you know
foray into it or kind of wants a leap of
faith but the first time that you choose
do that that's what sucks you into the
rabbit hole then you have skin in the
game then you're more interested in
learning
more as to why you just did what you did
and then the natural consequence of that
is if you're buying something knowing
very little about it you're you're
you're making a less informed decision
but then as you educate yourself you
start to understand the how the why and
your conviction level increases which
translates into becoming as tres Mayer
would say Hodler of last resort and
continuing to accumulate and continuing
to shift the the balance of whatever
whatever savings that you do have
increasing the into Bitcoin but but you
can only kind of get that education once
you're already in the game for sure the
next piece you wrote is a Bitcoin does
not waste energy and this is why one of
my favorite topics to talk to people
about but elaborate on you know what you
kind of covered in this piece yeah so
and this one I really swung for the
fences where you know there are a lot of
reasons when you when you get into the
kind of the brass tacks of the energy
that Bitcoin does consume there's a lot
of kind of micro level explanations that
we can that we can defend the energy use
of Bitcoin so and there are a number of
them it's it's kind of a site it's this
idea that realistically the sources of
energy consumption or production that
bitcoins going to compete for are not
going to replace or compete for the same
energy supply that say powers your home
there's there's the idea that a large
portion of the Bitcoin network in terms
of the energy that it consumes is is
renewable and that you know kind of the
Bitcoin only consumes the amount of
energy that the free market will bear
and that you know as a consequence of
Bitcoin and because of the dynamics of
the energy that it can consume that that
it will actually lead to more stable
energy grants in that you know it will
actually advance the the development of
renewable source of energy I kind of
stayed away from from that acid but
aspect but I really went to the first
principles and who is this idea and I
use then as well as an example but
before I even go there it's the idea of
kind of asking that question of like
what
and and in order to understand or to
form an appreciation for the amount of
energy that Bitcoin does consume you
have to have an appreciation for the
problem that it's solving if you do not
have an appreciation for the magnitude
of the problem that it's solving the
amount of any energy that it consumed
will never be deemed justifiable but
then when you understand money and you
understand money is the backbone that
allows our economies to function it's
the good that allows all other economic
activity to be coordinated you start to
understand the weight of the problem and
then when you look at it in the context
of ok what happens to an economy when a
form of money hyper inflates looking at
Argentina or Venezuela or or even Turkey
any you know there there's a number of
any hyperinflationary scenarios that you
can look at the the economic
consequences are devastating mm-hmm
and that and safe has a quote about this
where if you know if if Bitcoin prevents
one one instance of hyperinflation then
all of the energy consumed you know will
be a bargain bargain basement price and
it's that idea that if we think about
kind of everything that we use in our
daily lives is in some form or fashion
a an energy output there's an energy
input to create an energy output and
that that money is the economic good
that allows for the coordination of all
those energy inputs and outputs to to
get things that we take for granted
every day and are in our lives so not
thinking about the most complicated
things but just thinking about the basic
things food at the grocery store
yeah basic health care clean water you
know sanitation those type of things all
of that is only possible with a stable
form of money and when you don't have a
stable form of money those basic
necessities cannot be fulfilled and so
the approach that I took and in Bitcoin
does not waste energy it's this idea
that if if everything that we consume in
our daily lives is a derivative of some
energy consumption and if and if we want
that to be sustained then we need a
stable money supply so it's this idea
that every other form of energy
consumption is a derivative of money so
therefore the
and highest use of energy should first
be to secure the money supply because if
we don't secure the money supply every
everything else is MIT and so I used an
example where you know you look at
Venezuela and not just the fact that
they have you know gone into
hyperinflation but recognizing that
Venezuela is one of the most oil-rich or
energy rich countries in the world and
if you look at their energy production
year over year over the last five years
it's plummeted literally they can't get
the the trait they're trading currency
or oil out of the ground because they
don't have a reliable form of money and
so when we think into the future it is
not that bitcoin is going to you know
the energy that's consumed by the
Bitcoin network and otherwise could go
to power homes and in if we didn't have
bitcoins energy energy consumption we
could you know you know have you know
you know warm homes for six million more
poor people it's that if we don't have
that form of money everything else that
areas and so kind of the first order
function should be let's secure the
Bitcoin network and and then everything
else you know will follow from there for
sure and you know one of the things that
I think a lot about and mainly one of my
partners and I Jason Williams we one of
the first things we did in Bitcoin and
crypto was we built a mining facility at
a renewable energy plant rice we had
made an investment and they take car
tires they turn it into oil steel and
power sell the oil in the steel that
power essentially was kind of op X free
right because the business was
profitable I take the tire summit limo
steel power source build mine right
there rather than sell the power of the
grid very economic advantage for us but
also we sought out a renewable energy
source because the low cost power I
think a lot about the fact that there's
almost this game of like cat mouse or
like hide-and-seek around the world of
people who want to mine or secure the
network they are looking for lowest cost
power lowest cost power is usually
attributable to renewable energies and
so they are actively spending money time
energy intellectual capital to go seek
out those renewable energy sources and
then
to help monetize them and so if that
continues to play out can we actually
drive innovation and drive the kind of
build out of renewable energy sources
simply because of bitcoins securing the
money supply yeah and I do think that
there is merit to that in the sense that
now and I'll use an example of one of
our good friends in Texas Gideon Powell
who's out building infrastructure in
West Texas for for greenfield mining
Bitcoin mining and you know one of the
things out in West Texas is obviously
they all have natural gas but there's
also an incredible amount of wind power
and in solar power and so I do think
that you know one Bitcoin mining will
increasingly go out to the periphery
where the cheapest sources of power
actually exists and then it also
incentivizes the the lowest marginal
cost of power and in Bitcoin energy
consumption is unique in the sense that
it's demanded 24/7 which is a dream for
either an energy grid or an energy
producer when you think about you know
kind of any network that requires a
significant amount of infrastructure you
know whether it's a telecom network or
an energy grid there's generally peak
demand and trough demand and there's
generally you know only a few points in
you know during the year where a peak
demand is Reese or a few points in the
day and that the the the nature of
bitcoins energy demand being that it's
24/7 specifically or I think you know
tangibly will lead to the you I guess
innovation around technology in
renewable energy because one of the
biggest challenges and again I'm not an
energy expert but it's just common sense
that you know the storage of that you
know of that renewable energy is costly
and it's one of the biggest challenges
but if if you reliably know that you're
consuming power 24/7 the storage of that
power becomes less important because
you're you're literally consuming it as
fast as you can produce it for sure that
makes complete sense to me the next one
in the series is Bitcoin fixes this what
does that mean and what would you cover
there yeah so there I went back to what
we talked about a little bit earlier
really
brought me to Bitcoin and really had the
idea you know one Bitcoin fixes this is
you know something that the
Twittersphere you know it's a great meme
it's a great me and it's this at a high
level it's the idea that a stable form
of money or a sound form of money or
form of money was divorced from the
state that's not subject to the
political whims of a few people sitting
around the table are not naturally even
political whims that's not fair to say
to the Fen but you know kind of a
limited knowledge base or a little
limited scope of ability of you know a
very few number of people managing the
money of an economy that supports 300
million people that as we shift to a
world of sound money of a stable form of
money that there will be a natural
balancing effect that will solve a lot
of the the problems that people can feel
around them but maybe not maybe haven't
identified is fundamentally driven by an
unstable form of money or an easy form
of money so that's that's the high-level
context of Bitcoin fixes this but then
specifically what I talk about in this
piece is really you know again I think
about the reason why Bitcoin exists is
because ultimately you have some very
smart individual forward-thinking people
solve a problem that many people did not
and created a technology that created a
solution for that problem the practical
reason why Bitcoin exists is because the
forms of money that we're using today
are not reliable and in are subject to
not just debasement but but systemic the
basement and and really the basement
that the legacy system is inherent
on in order to function and so what
bitcoin fixes this is about and
specifically in the graduate and
suddenly piece is the idea that bitcoin
fixes QE each time and when you know
we're just starting to see I don't know
if we can officially say that you know
what the Fed is doing in the repo
markets is officially QE 4 but QE 4 will
be announced in short order in my view
it's inevitable at this piece the ECB is
already single signaled additional QE I
don't think the Bank of Japan ever stops
and I think they've even gone as far
you know the ECB excetera is saying that
it's kind of like the new normal
right light leg it's not just gonna be
another you know limited point in time
where there's QE introduced it is
basically this is now necessary to
continue kind of a charade right yeah
and really if people are interested in
understanding that the reason why that
is is because of the size of the Fiat
credit systems the size of the credit
system and the degree of leverage that
exists cannot be sustained unless the
base my supplies increase the whole
system is based on that dynamic of the
the relative scarcity of the base money
to the the overall size of the credit
system but then when you recognize that
all QE is designed to do or what it's
designed to enable is to allow an
unsustainable system to be sustained QE
in the way that the central bankers view
kind of in managing their economies is I
need to expand the credit system because
if I'm not expanding the credit system
then I have a deflationary environment
the only thing that was worse than
inflation to a to a central banker is
deflation and in this context if they
just let the system go it would collapse
on itself and so that is the reason why
QE is not just a tool that will be
periodically used as it's actually a
necessary function to the to the way
that the existing system is constructed
and so when we think about Bitcoin and
those of us that that recognize this
problem and why this this form of medium
that is Bitcoin is superior to this
legacy system that is you know
fed puts more QE in so the credit system
can increase we get to a situation where
we have two more too much debt and then
we need to put more base money in which
is QE that that ultimately now Bitcoin
represents monetary competition if if
people believe that that is that the
path to economic stability or prosperity
is central bank's managing the money
supply managing the economy from Central
Command they have their legacy monetary
system but for those of us that are that
are starting to see it clearly and just
into see that this is a never-ending
cycle that we increasingly opt out and
so by Bitcoin having a fixed supply that
I you know we all think about Bitcoin
having a fixed supply but really in a
root level Bitcoin supply is dictated by
consensus so while we think about it as
a fixed supply it's it's really only
fixed so long as the market participants
that are involved want it to be fixed
and then it so happens that a group of
rational economic actors have
independently opted into a fixed supply
currency system would not in an
overwhelmingly you know large way form a
consensus to debase that currency we
basically now have monetary policy by
consensus rather than than by Fiat and
in you know kind of over the course of
the 20th century whether it was you know
the conversation or the debate between
Hayek and Keynes
ultimately we ended up in a whirl where
where we have Keynesian and monitors the
basement of the money supply as the
mechanism to achieve economic stability
that was always an intellectual debate
the Keynesian one now we have free
market competition we've got two systems
that is every single day being evaluated
by market participants all over the
world and the signal of value going up
in Bitcoin is more people looking at
this question and coming out on the side
that hey if I was contributing value
today I would rather be opting into a
system that had a fixed supply rather
than one that I know is going to be
debased so kind of in that general
context it is human Bitcoin fixes this
at at a root level or at a fundamental
level it is presenting a monetary option
that that is an opt-out path for the
legacy system yeah it's fantastic and I
think that's why people have gravitated
towards that idea which you just
articulated the last in the series is
Bitcoin not blockchain which is a play
on words I think of a lot of people
saying you know blockchain not Bitcoin
describe a little bit about what you
covered in this in this last one yeah so
and also just to say for all the
listeners it won't be the last one is
the last one he's published yeah the
last one that I've published and so
again this one is is getting to you know
coming back to the center of if Bitcoin
fixes this is you know really the
economic rationale
for for--why Bitcoin exists and kind of
addressing this problem statement
between what was something that we were
all forced topped into versus now having
an option topped out that Bitcoin out
blotching is then going back and
focusing on the technicals of Bitcoin
and it's it's helping you know it's
expanding upon the idea why bitcoin
can't be copied but then it's also
trying to distill for people why a lot
of a lot of people I think look at the
and I try not to reference the Bitcoin
community but for for the people that
that have come to this view that Bitcoin
is the only blockchain that works it's
the only blockchain that matters there's
this idea that somehow we have this
closed-minded view and that oh you know
what what's the fun of this whole thing
if we only have one currency to rule
them all and really it's not an
ideological belief like it's not
something that we just want it's
something that we have reason to based
on first principles and so when I walk
through in Bitcoin blockchain is trying
to give people who have some tools at a
really base level as to how Bitcoin
works and then build up from those kind
of base building blocks to then walk
through the rationale as to okay now if
you have this baseline as to how Bitcoin
actually works at a technical level and
how the currency interplays with the
blockchain what the blockchain actually
is then I can walk you back up to the to
the first principles as to why we think
that this then obsoletes every other
form of of currency and so I'm walking
into a little bit of that it's or if I
was to distill it down into ideas it is
that you know first recognize that that
Bitcoin was designed to solve a very
specific problem it was designed to
solve a problem that exists in modern
money and that the blockchain was a tool
that the founder of Bitcoin used
specifically to remove a central third
party from that equation how can we
validate and verify either the scarcity
asset or the
that asset is not previously to be spent
without a central party the only way to
do that is for all parties to have a
copy of all the all the transactions
that have ever happened for sure the
thing that I think is so interesting
about this is you're taking a single
asset right which is Bitcoin and you're
coming at it from so many different
angles and some of it is you're
disproving or arguing against the
detractions you're also kind of
enhancing or highlighting some of the
positive arguments and so I'm very see
kind of how many of these you can write
right and I think that there's a lot
more to go or so some I'm super pumped
about it remind us where folks can go in
and read them yeah so all of the blog is
that are all the series is available at
Unchained - capital dot-com slash blog
and you can you can there's a there's a
tag for graduate and suddenly so they're
all listed there on the entry and
capital website and then I also each
week you can sign up for the newsletter
on the website and then I also
distribute them on Twitter each time I
release them so we'll be out with
another one next week which will be
bitcoins not backed by nothing which is
one of the things that you know again a
lot of the times that I write I think to
the institutional audience that you know
one it's a broad resource that anyone in
Bitcoin that has friends that are
interested can point to then we're also
thinking about educating future clients
bun change so it's creating a repository
that as each person is going you know
down the rabbit hole these are all
questions that most people come to in
the past
and have to overcome to kind of come to
this point of view that Bitcoin likely
will be and I think the probability is
increasing with every day that bitcoin
is a will be a global reserve asset for
sure where where do we go from here
right like what is the future of Bitcoin
look like and how does that unfold or
evolve in your opinion given what you
know today so one I think that you know
it it's increasingly not practical for
people to ignore Bitcoin so I think that
we're getting to the the point
I know that through Morgan Creek you
guys have started to get institutional
investors involved and not only having
exposure to Bitcoin but then also
infrastructure that's being built around
Bitcoin I think it you know to an
economic system that has a purchasing
power of two hundred billion and each
time that it doesn't die and and then
people see that that it continues to
rise and value they can ignore
fewer and fewer people can ignore that
reality and then as you know fortune 500
companies get involved like square and
the CME that provides a lot of cover for
us where it's not it's not this medium
that's just for criminals it's not this
digital nothingness it's it's actually
there there is rationale and there is
reason as to why there's fundamental
demand I think that where we go from
here I think that one we recognized that
still very few people a whole Bitcoin
the people that do for an even in fewer
number of those people does it represent
a significant portion of their wealth
that that educational resources are
continuing to increase and the people
are you know a kind of in an exponential
way educating themselves on Bitcoin I
think that we're gonna we're gonna see a
really interesting dynamic between
Bitcoin adoption and in the cycles of QE
I think that ultimately this the state
and central banks are going to be there
is going to be a fight in terms of
control and I think that you know I
don't you know there's no crystal ball
in terms of how that fight plays out but
I think that yeah kind of heavier
regulation kind of trying to you know
whether it's the the Fed you know
combining with the ECB or the BOJ to in
some ways try to deregulate it out of
existence I think it's going to be very
difficult to do I think the positive
side is that they only probably get
there until Bitcoin burn not until
Bitcoin represents a trillion dollars of
wealth or two trillion dollars of wealth
and I think the path that you know where
we where we go from today
there is increasing education but then
also building infrastructure like a lot
of people look at Bitcoin and and you
know say like oh this could never be a
form of money but what they don't
recognize that or I want to say they
don't recognize but it's not looking at
the long game and it's thinking a very
short-sighted context of you know
Bitcoin went from zero to where it is
today in ten years if we think about the
internet we have to build infrastructure
to increase usability increase security
can give people confidence that when
they're storing this they're storing it
securely so I think the the next phase
is going to be I think we're still
trying to solve custody solutions that
work and so that's what we're focus on
it Unchained I think where we're gonna
see a lot of competition in that space
and a lot of different models tribe but
as we perfect those models that gives
people increased comfort that you know
whatever assets that they store in
Bitcoin are secure as people gain
conviction in that then it been that
further increases adoption for sure I
think it's a very clearly articulated
path and and one that's very likely
known before I finished up I was do
rapid-fire questions what do you think
is the most important company in Bitcoin
other than Unchained Square treasure Oh
square yeah so either so an on-ramp and
those that are building hardware to to
help people secure their own their own
Bitcoin and that it allows but going to
be decentralized and allows kind of for
the the properties of decentralization
and sistership resistance to increase
over time so somebody was literally
tweeting at me this morning saying has
anyone ever answered was Square and I
said I can't remember if someone has or
not but there would be a very strong
argument so so I could put any clue that
said yeah yeah that's even better
yeah what's the one regulation you would
change or improve if you could either
the qualify custodianship or MLK OSC
yeah I think that those are both areas
that
we have one we are in this world where
we are we are trying to as a not
necessarily as a collective but through
to be a competition solving different
models as to how to secure Bitcoin
requiring a lot of regulatory overhead
to you know just put a a regulators view
as to what in Bitcoin qualifies as
someone that can actually secure Bitcoin
is is trying to be a fit a square peg in
a round hole and and then on the other
side I think that and this is something
that we struggle with as a company you
know as bitcoiners I think everyone is
is increasingly conscious of privacy and
how important that is
but then as a financial institution we
are required to comply with certain laws
that I think inevitably and really
undebatable II create risk for a lot of
law-abiding citizens and so you know
it's it's the unintended consequences of
of those AML kyc policies that create
create risk for people while maybe well
intentioned or you know there's probably
a range of people who think well
intention or not well intention but
there are unintended consequences and so
yeah but those are the rules and so we
are as a financial institution we comply
with them but I think that we are now
looking at a new medium and so both on
the qualified custodianship and a male
kyc I think we have to recognize of what
it is that what the subject matter is
that we're dealing with and what is the
right way whether there is a right way
to regulate mm-hmm for sure what's the
most controversial thought you have you
have in Bitcoin so when you say it the
most people be I call I disagree with
that okay so a lot of people believe
that everybody gets to define Bitcoin by
running a full note um I don't I think
that what a node allows you to do is
asset whether something is Bitcoin or
not and so you know it may be splitting
hairs but
you know I think about it in the context
of you know you can change Bitcoin and
you can fork Bitcoin if you do not win a
consensus then it's not Bitcoin and so
so that's that's like that's the first
principle that I use to say you know a
node doesn't allow you to define Bitcoin
for yourself it just allows you to
assess whether you're in consensus of
the network mm-hmm
what's the most important book you've
ever read maybe the Bitcoin Center so
Dean won't mind that yeah I mean it's
definitely up there a world in debt is
up there and then the Road to Serfdom
the Road to Serfdom maybe I think from
on a societal level the most important
yeah I haven't read that I need to pick
that one up yeah I definitely recommend
it for for anyone that's you know
whether you're interested in Bitcoin or
not you know is it Hayek is a economist
but he's floss for as much as an
economist and it really the Road to
Serfdom
provides a really first principle view
as to why socialism fails and why it is
so not only in contrast but is in
opposition to individual freedoms so I
do recommend that everybody got it I
wrap up each podcast letting the guests
ask me one question but first we talked
a lian's believer non-believer did you
go to area 51 did not go to area 51
don't think about it a lot okay I think
just on probabilities probably yeah but
I find that's the most common answer
right it's just look you know who knows
but on a mathematical basis you know
that there's a lot of a lot of space out
there and it is highly likely more than
anything what one question do you have
for me to finish up what is the first
state or nation to to buy Bitcoin or
adopt it okay so two different questions
adopt first by I'm gonna go out on a
limb and say that we're recording this
in
was it September 2018 or 2019 I'm
guessing a states already bought some I
don't know who but you know I would have
some kind of likely candidates but my
guess is that somebody somewhere has
bought some even though it's a little
bit and and are holding it I don't know
if it's in like central bank reserve Rex
I think that that might be a little
aggressive but definitely states have
some Bitcoin right through seizures and
stuff like that but actually actively
purchasing it I think probably has
happened in terms of adopting it I think
it's gonna be the reverse of what
everyone is thinking so it's not gonna
be the developer all it's gonna be some
developing country maybe one that
suffers from hyperinflation maybe not
but it's also likely going to be
attached to size so the smaller country
is probably the less bureaucratic it is
which also means that there's less risk
because the least amount of people are
kind of going to be subjected to the
experiment if you will and so you know
you see these countries like the Malta's
the Marshall Islands you know all those
things I don't know if it's that small
as much as it might be a country with
you know kind of low single-digit
millions of people and and the thing I'm
waiting for is like the first country
that gets a Bitcoin er as the leader I
think a lot of stuff will change very
quickly right so it's almost like you
have to have somebody at the very top
which believes or understands and
therefore the top-down approach will
accelerate their embracing of it or
their adoption of it yeah that makes
sense i mean i think that we're sitting
here in wyoming so but yeah the the
state here is doing a lot of things to
create regulatory certainty for for
crypto and bitcoin related companies so
i think that you know likely is some
some entity that has or some state or
nation that has you know the
kind of forward-thinking kind of is
investing the resources to attract the
type of people and that as a consequence
of education and familiarity that that
they see the benefit in terms of
securing a portion of whatever is in
their Treasury Reserve so they'll be
interesting to see for sure where where
can people find you Twitter elsewhere
online I'm generally only active on
Twitter so Parker a Lewis at Parker a
Lewis on Twitter and then follow the
follow the Graduate and suddenly series
reach out to me I love to engage so
awesome and let people know or let
Parker know if you're gonna be in Austin
Texas as well so yeah we do host the
Austin Bitcoin developers Meetup justin
moon organizes it but we hosted our
luncheon capital hard to say
headquarters but but our office down and
in Austin so if you're in Austin we've
got a increasing number of bitcoiners
there so look us up for it we're around
awesome man thank so much for doing this
I appreciate hey everyone pop here if
you like this episode of off the chain
and want to help us take crypto to the
top of the Apple Spotify and other
podcast charts please do us a favor and
rate review and subscribe to review
simply go to the off-the-chain homepage
scroll down until you see the five blank
stars taking 15 seconds to fill those
stars in and leave a quick review goes a
long way in helping us take the entire
crypto ecosystem to the top of the
charts
I appreciate you listening and see you
next time on off the chain